so it's my pleasure to welcome the next
speaker a Priya who's from University
who's gonna be talking about inverse
optimal power flow assessing the
vulnerability of power grid data Pyrrha
is a third-year PhD student in the
computer science department and
Department of engineering and public
policy at CMU her research is in the
intersection of deep learning and energy
policy exploring topics such as marginal
emissions prediction grid data
vulnerability and end to end task based
approaches for coordinating between grid
forecasting and control thank you okay
yeah thanks so much for having me here
so my name is Priya Dundee and I'll be
talking about some work that's joint
with my advisers at CMU in a Acevedo and
Zico Coulter on assessing the
vulnerability of data on the power grid
so there is a lot of public data on the
u.s. power system and I would argue that
it's for very good reasons
so grid operators for example publish
energy prices on a relatively granular
scale in order to promote market
transparency and the US Environmental
Protection Agency also publishes how
much electricity large fossil generators
are producing at each hour in order to
do emissions monitoring so I mean argue
that there's a lot of data out there for
very good reasons on the other hand
there is also a lot of power grid data
that we would like to keep private so
for example electricity generators in
some parts of the u.s. bid into a market
in order to compete to produce
electricity and if one electricity
generator were to know another
electricity generators costs they could
game their bids in order to try to
produce more electricity and this could
drive prices up for consumers so as a
result we'd like to keep generators
bidding costs hidden in order to promote
market efficiency and fairness as
another example we would like to keep
things about the grid structure hidden
in particular a
an adversary we're to know certain
aspects of the power grid structure they
could potentially hack the grid or make
it collapse and so this is potentially a
cybersecurity concern and so as a result
grid operators have invested a lot of
time in trying to figure out how exactly
to either keep data private or to react
to the exposure of data that they would
like to otherwise not have be public and
there have been a lot of prior
approaches to this so in markets and
electricity markets there's a
combination of retroactive approaches
and proactive approaches so retroactive
approaches ask the question can I look
at how my market operated in the past
and see if it was actually operating
efficiently and fairly and then
proactive approaches include mechanism
design so can we actually design markets
that are going to operate efficiently
and fairly given what we know about the
actual system on the cyber security side
some folks would do threat modeling so
asking questions like who or what can
threaten the power system and how
exactly would that happen as an input to
both of these kinds of analyses one
would need to do a data of data
vulnerability assessment so ask the
question can we understand what
information on the power system is
actually at risk and then use that
information to actually do our
cybersecurity assessments and our market
efficiency assessments and so the work
that we present here is kind of in this
third camp we're trying to try to assess
the vulnerability of data on the system
and so specifically the question we're
asking in this work is whether private
power grid information can be reverse
engineered from public power grid
information so specifically as I
mentioned earlier in the u.s. we tend to
know how much power electricity
generators are putting into the system
at a given time and we also tend to know
the energy prices at various places on
the system what we don't want to know
where we don't want release is the
actual costs at which electricity
generators are bidding into the system
and we also don't want released the grid
structure however we do know how the
public and
quantities are related to each other
they're related through a problem called
AC optimal power flow and this is
basically the mechanism through which
grid operators schedule electricity
generation in order to minimize the
system costs and so the way we formulate
our reverse engineering problem the
ability to reverse engineer private data
from public is there something we are
calling inverse optimal power flow
essentially can we find the inputs to
the AC opf problem to the AC optimal
power flow problem that produce public
outputs that look like the data that we
actually observe on the system so
basically if we estimate generator costs
and grid structure do we actually get
power generation and electricity prices
that match the powered power generation
at electricity prices that we see in the
real world so the way we solve this
inverse optimal power flow problem is
through gradient descent a pretty
standard method and here's the
pseudocode for that algorithm at a high
level what the pseudocode is saying is
that we start with a bunch of public
data and also some initial guesses for
what we think that the private parameter
is what we think the costs and grid
structure should be we then going
through this basically we take our
guesses we put it through the AC optimal
powerful algorithm and we get some
estimates for what we think the public
quantities should be and we compute the
loss between or the error between the
public quantities that we estimate and
the public quantities that we actually
see and then we use the information
about that error to update our estimates
for what we think the private data is so
essentially while there is some gap
between what our algorithm thinks the
public data should be and what the
public data actually is we iteratively
use the gradient of this error to update
our parameters and when our outputs
match the real public data we stop so in
principle this algorithm looks actually
relatively simple but there's something
tricky about it that I haven't told you
yet and that is exactly what does this
ace
optimal power flow problem look like and
in particular AC optimal power flow is
actually an optimization problem so the
formulation is here on the slide and in
particular grid operators will try to
minimize electricity costs that's the
objective of the problem subject to some
linear inequality and equality
constraints that we might have on the
system as well as one can straight than
we call the power flow constraint that
basically describes the physical
attributes of the power grid to relate
this to the inverse problem that I show
above this variable Z that power
operators are optimizing over is what
contains the power generation and for
those who this means anything to the
dual variables on that power flow
constraint are actually what our
electricity prices are but for those who
may not know what that means basically
the AC optimal power flow formulation is
what is giving us our estimates of power
generation and electricity prices and
the tricky part about this is that now
what you see on the screen in front of
you is an optimization problem embedded
within an optimization problem and this
is actually what we're trying to somehow
take gradients through and so to go back
to our stochastic gradient descent or a
gradient descent algorithm here to
compute that particular gradient that's
highlighted in the red box to compute
the gradient that we need to update our
public parameter guesses we need to
compute something like this so in
particular for each parameter we're
trying to guess we have to compute the
gradient of the loss with respect to
that parameter and if you run out the
chain rule you'll get something that
looks like this and in particular the
thing I'd like to highlight is that
taking this and this gradient involves
taking gradients through the outputs of
the AC opf optimization problem so we
have to know what the gradient of the
power generation is with respect to our
parameters and what the power prices is
with respect to our parameters so the
way we actually do this the way we
actually differentiate through the AC
optimal power flow problem I'll talk
about this at a high level but you're
welcome to ask me details after the
first step is that we formulate this
optima
problem as a quadratic program are
actually a sequence of quadratic
programs that we solve and then at the
end when we've actually solved the
problem we write out what are called the
KKT conditions of that problems so the
conditions to fit that are necessary and
sufficient to describe the optimal
conditions of that problem we take
derivatives through those KKT conditions
and use that to write out a linear
system we can use to solve for the
gradients and that linear system is what
you see on the slide in practice we're
actually able to really efficiently
compute these gradients using back
propagation in a neural network
so to recap and if those last two slides
didn't make sense to you don't worry too
much about it the main idea here is that
essentially we are able to
reverse-engineer to some extent the AC
optimal power flow problem that power
operators used to schedule electricity
and by doing that we can try to extract
some of the private information on the
power grid from public information so in
theory this is all well and good but can
does this actually work and so at the
moment we've started to test this out on
a couple of power system test cases with
a plan to expand to testing on larger
systems later on and so on the next few
slides I'll show you our preliminary
results for a 14 node test case where we
assume we have 200 points of public data
and in these experiments instead of
assuming that we don't know anything
about the system and then trying to
learn everything we kind of started by
saying imagine we only don't know some
part of the data can we recover it so in
our first set of experiments we assume
we know everything about the structure
of the power grid but that we don't know
anything about the costs that the
electricity generators are bidding into
the market so on the graph shown here
what we have is the results for three
different electricity generators on the
system and on the y-axis is the squared
error of our estimate for two different
cost parameters for each generator on
the x-axis what you see is that we ran
multiple experiments we're in one set of
experiments in which we assumed we only
had one piece of public data and we kind
of increased the public data over time
so 5 10 up to 200 points of data and
what we found
that actually with as few as five data
points we were actually able to
completely determine what the
electricity generation costs were on the
system so admittedly for those who know
power systems a 14 bus test case is
actually a relatively small test case it
is far from the scale of a full power
system that said five data points is
also far less than what you would have
on the power system and particularly
actually have this data the public data
hourly over multiple years so that's a
couple tens of thousands of data points
and so these preliminary results seem to
indicate that the data that is published
right now may expose generator costs on
the actual system to so guessing
generator costs was pretty easy but
guessing the grid structure is a bit
harder and to explain that I'm going to
show the results of one experimental run
or two experimental runs one for two
different parameters as we progress in
our algorithm so that's the graph shown
here on the x-axis is our quote unquote
public loss so this distance between our
estimates of the public quantities and
the real public quantities that I was
talking about before and when the loss
is high towards the left of the graph
that's the start of our algorithm and as
we optimize our algorithm we move right
words on this graph so at the rightmost
side of this graph is where we've
actually stopped our algorithm and said
I think we have the correct guesses for
our private parameters and on the y-axis
is a squared error of our guests for the
parameters one parameter is a solid blue
line and the other one is a dash torrent
line and since grid structural
parameters are complex quantities this
is actually the real part of the grid
structural parameters that you're seeing
here and then we also have a plot for
the imaginary part and the part of the
graph that we want to look like is look
at is this very right side so when we
stop the algorithm when our loss over
the public quantity is zero have we
actually recovered the private parameter
correctly and here in one case we have
in one case the loss for that parameter
is the squared error of the private
parameter is zero at the right side of
the graph but for the other one we have
and so we can frame this in terms of
identifiability basically some
structural parameters are easily
identifiable they do actually determine
the outputs of the system and others
don't so again these are preliminary
results on a 14 bus test case and we're
looking to expand our analysis and make
it more robust going forward so for in
the last minute I kind of want to talk
about what this analysis means for
policymaking so what can policymakers
actually do based on the results of our
preliminary and eventually final
analysis so the first option they have
is actually to stop publishing data of
course as a data scientist that makes me
kind of sad and in particular I don't
necessarily think that's I think that's
a great idea in that as I mentioned
before there are really good reasons
that the public data is public for
market transparency and environmental
objectives and so there's actually a
huge toolkit of options that
policymakers can use besides restricting
data access to improve the grid based on
the results of this analysis so on the
market side there's the option to based
on knowledge of exactly what data is
leaked to design more robust markets
that won't break even if that data is
exposed there are also things we can do
outside the market like pay generators -
in ways that incentivize them to not
game the system and we can also update
our heuristics so currently power system
operators have heuristics to determine
if somebody is actually unfairly
operating on the system and so based on
the data we have we can update these
heuristics to actually catch people who
might be offending here on the
cybersecurity side there are actually a
couple of things we can do as well so
for instance Idaho National Lab has a
power grid testbed that is used for a
variety of things data mining cyber
security analysis for the power system
and so one could potentially give Civic
hackers the outputs of our analysis say
you know these grid structural
parameters what parts of the system can
you actually break based on that and
then based on the results that the Civic
hackers are able to obtain we can
actually design measures and policies to
fix that
and of course we can also use formal
system verification methods so actually
go do the mathematics of the system to
see what breaks or doesn't break based
on the information available so to
summarize in this talk we proposed a
method for assessing power grid data
vulnerability by reverse engineering the
AC optimal power flow problem and what
we want to say is that policy makers
have a variety of options that they can
use in order to use the results of this
analysis to make the grid more robust
and with that I'd like to say thanks
thank you so much to the organizers of
this workshop and if we have time for
questions thanks thank you any questions
so I have one this is moving now to
decentralize and distribute the actual
generation to go to like rooftop or
smaller solar panels penally you know
yards how does this still pose a threat
or does this prevent the threat or is
this these issues still present yeah I
think to be determined I think these
issues would definitely still be present
even in the presence of rooftop solar
so one kind of wrinkle that comes along
with rooftop solar is that these that
solar panels input power into a part of
the grid called the distribution grid
that's the part of the grid that's the
closest to consumers and historically we
don't actually have a bunch of sensors
on that system because we didn't expect
to have a two-way flow of power there
and as a result in some sense I would
argue that there's a little more room
for for fudging or weird behavior
because if power system operators don't
know what's going on in that part of the
system then they don't necessarily know
what's going wrong on that part of the
system
if somebody's gaming on the other hand
of course if these power if these solar
panels are not bidding into the market
then all of a sudden we have a much more
a larger pool of power that's no longer
in the market and so as a result the
influence of the market and the kind of
effect of gaming on the market is much
less widespread so I'd say the jury is
for sure out on whether distributed
solar for example will help her hurt in
this case yeah
some more questions this method works
because you know what optimization
algorithm the power companies are using
if the companies chose to stay slightly
suboptimal and did that in a slight in a
random manner with them would it still
work so yeah so the question you asked
is if they did and actually the answer
to that is they currently do you
suboptimal algorithms to schedule the
power system and so no I didn't mean
suboptimal algorithms mmm-hmm no one
algorithm but stay on an excellence
above sub optimality set I see no so I
mean I guess what I'm saying is they
could do that or they currently use
known algorithms but different
algorithms that are actually worse for
the system so the I think the question
you're asking if I'm understanding
correctly is are we actually using the
correct model here to model what the
power system is after the power
operators are actually doing to model
the system and so I guess there's a
two-fold answer to that there is one I'm
a student how sharp is the optimal set
right right and so I guess what I'm
saying is there's one possibility that
the ACC optimal power flow our algorithm
is brittle enough that we would then not
be able to actually ever get to zero
public loss on the system but on the
other hand if we are able to you and I
think the jury's out on that if we are
able to then even though the power
system operators are using a different
algorithm than we are at that point if
you're able to basically describe how
the system is working then you can still
fudge with it so yeah thanks what was it
one more question
[Applause]